the temperature is rising again
over already bone dry soil
and with it rises the risk of fire
particularly on farms as diesel-powered
machinery heads into tinder-dry fields
to harvest
and when they happen the fire service is
expecting them to be at least as severe
as those like licky hill in
worcestershire back in july naturally
was going uphill
it jumped over the road which we would
historically would have used as a fire
break
but it jumped that and it was heading
down towards the houses that direction
the
intensity and speed of the fire was
greater than we're not used to expecting
we had the predictions we had the fire
severity index telling us it was an
exceptional risk day
and that's very rare i haven't seen many
of those days and to see it booked for
three four days in a row especially as
it's forecast for this weekend for the
southeast
um yeah
high temperatures low humidity it's got
all the sort of danger signs that if a
fire does start it's going to spread
quickly and with intensity it's exactly
a month since the licky hills fire and
around me not a hint of green vegetation
coming up out of this burnt soil and
that's testament to just how dry it's
continued to be and how the potential
for more wildfires is even greater now
than it was if fires do start their
severity in southern and eastern parts
of the uk is forecast to be very high
right now but the situation worsens as
the heat continues into the weekend
by friday some pockets in the south and
east could see fires of exceptional
severity into the weekend that level
expands across large parts of the south
and east and by sunday the majority of
the south east and midlands will be at
risk of exceptional fires this winter we
just didn't get the rain so we haven't
had the recharge so the reservoirs the
rivers and all the lakes are incredibly
low so we don't have the water what we
need is that classic british rain where
we get lots of light rain all the time
which will allow it to soak into the
soil and actually recharge the aquifers
and our reservoirs officials are meeting
tomorrow and expected to declare formal
drought status in the southwest and
possibly other regions of england later
on
rain and cooler temperatures are
forecast for next week that will
certainly reduce fire risk but it will
take a significant change in the weather
to even start to reverse the impact of
this historic dry spell tom clark sky
news